you listen to uh Drake
yeah or 55 cents because the moment that
your body starts to
you start to kind of like move to the
music you start the Bops to the music he
he puts the hot sauce in there like we
know this if you ask anyone they say we
know this but then it's like how often
do you actually reflect on it so maybe
all those other trucks like right next
to us and everything so those other we
almost we could almost die yeah subhanah
look how quickly life can just take a
turn subhanallah I suppose parental
discretion advised and this is for
mature audiences this is
thank you
this is
the danger
[Music]
please welcome to the game show got an
exciting episode for you guess who's in
the dean show studio and Hell how you
doing
how about yourself alhamdulillah we had
a close one yesterday didn't we huh yes
sir yeah sir that was uh really uh and
and it was something that uh took me by
surprise how about you yeah oh for sure
people like what are you guys talking
about maybe it's a good way to kick off
the kick off uh the program yeah yeah
yeah tell them tell them what happened
uh we were we were having a pretty deep
conversation
and and I like what you said you said
Allah was on our tongues and on our
minds right and then it seemed like
someone came over from the other lane
and we were almost like back then
because you had the karita yeah the
writer right yeah that brick wall right
there
so it was a close call it just came over
and we had to swear I've almost rammed
into that wall potentially yeah yeah
yeah so maybe just just by that much
yeah
and that just happened so quick
yeah and that's it just shows uh
how life can just take a turn
of a life
it shows how like temporary it all is
and and how it can all end like that you
know and it's moments like that that
makes us reflect and like I was telling
you yesterday like how often do we
actually reflect
that this is temporary that we we are
going to pass at some point you know
like we know this if you ask anyone they
say we know this but then it's like how
often do you actually reflect on it
that's the real question
but we were we were having that was a
good thing because you can be
in a state where you're not even at all
conscious that's why the Muslim is
always trying to have
the consciousness of his creator at all
times he's
or she's doing thicker right uh try not
to in those moments where let's say
you're not working or you some wherever
the case subhanallah alhamdulillah
you're having meaningful conversations
you're you know you're you're um
always in a state of taqwa right God
consciousness
and that was powerful when you said that
we were we were actually we were that's
what we're doing yeah in a way it wasn't
it
it's um it's funny too like when when we
do the thicker and we say these things
it's really false
yeah it's not for Allah like Allah
doesn't need that it's for us because it
reminds us it keeps that taqwa and um
like you said even the conversation that
we were having just speaking about Allah
or maybe just something that has to
revolve around that that's a form of
decorating of itself
now imagine see that's that versus
you listen to uh Drake
yeah or 55 cents or uh give me 50 Cent
50 cents yeah it's not 60. no no no
huh you know has anybody ever said you
kind of resembled this guy Drake yeah uh
my beer was shorter a few people used to
say it you're a better looking version
of Drake
so you've been told that when you when
your Beard's shorter yeah yeah there's
uh so you could be listening to the
Drake
and now you know recently he had in the
you know it's it's crazy you know the
kind of things that people are are the
topics people are discussing uh you
heard of this hot sauce thing yeah yeah
the hot sauce in the condom see this is
it's crazy it's kind of like you even
have this Tim in the shyness to talk
about it but you know this is the
reality of from a
point where you have people who are you
know reflecting over their purpose
living their purpose you know not
getting into just paltry useless
conversations and then or you have
people who are listening to Drake he's
like is he I'm Out Of Tune is he like
from what you is he one of the most
still famous was he a rapper R B artist
uh to be honest I don't know if he's
still one of the most I'm guessing he is
I don't listen to rap music anymore but
when I did back in the day he was
it was definitely up there you know yeah
is he a rapper or is he a uh
so he started off as like an r b yeah or
not even r b but just like kind of like
a singer
and then he started doing rapping
um now whether the rapping is is him or
not you know that's regardless of the
case but for the most part he's known as
a rap rapper yeah let's just touch upon
this and inshallah we can derive some
some good and we can get some people you
know a way to really thinking more
deeply about
some of these things that we're talking
about and I think this would be probably
for the maybe some Drake fan will tune
in right and this would be the one of
the most meaningful purposeful
conversations that they've listened to
in a very long time and they can reap
some benefits inshallah so I guess uh
because it usually it just revolves
around and then you know going coming
from that life that people have lived in
the past it kind of revolves around the
same thing what just music
alcohol drugs and for men
so I guess this story revolves the hot
sauce story with Drake revolves around
that he hooks up with some uh Instagram
model he's like come on let's go and
she don't her fitra has been
contaminated right usually a modest
woman shy woman is going to be like you
know insulted by that but he's the man
supposedly right in in the modern world
and she's like
let's go what happens from there
yeah it was the story then that's it
they get down
and then I guess she wants to like uh
get a she wants to get pregnant probably
by him so she tries to take that what's
in the you know the the balloon
and then he ends up putting the hot
sauce in there
parental discretion advised and this is
for mature audiences but inshallah
discussing this inshallah we can you
know for those Minds who never even get
to because now
um you know they're so consumed with so
many of of the things that are out there
now hopefully this what me and our
brother are talking about hopefully this
can make a lot of sense and we can
awaken the fitra of the human being
so you so so you see then she ends up no
modesty no Haya she's already you know
that's her opportunity to hit it big and
she's probably equating happiness with
this now if I can just hit it big I can
get the baby inside me from him from
that man Drake you know he's probably
the Elvis Presley of our timer would you
say something like that or Mike Jackson
um but he ends up you know playing he
he's he puts the hot sauce in there
Allah all this is true you know what I
mean or this whatever but this is what's
like people are talking about not us
what we are now but you know uh with a
Different Twist to it so he puts the hot
sauce
in in the balloon and she gets burnt and
now she wants to sue
what do you think
there's a lot to unpack right so the
first thing is that
when you're dealing with women outside
of uh Islam or just outside of religion
in general
um there's this terminology known as
hypergamy have you ever heard of it yes
yes okay so for those who aren't
familiar hypogamy is like uh one a woman
seeks to be with the highest value male
now what
consists of the highest value that
depends upon each
each woman right but if a woman sees
um this man you know Drake High status
he's just
like like you said in the Elvis Presley
of all the time kind of you know in a
sense
she's going to want to be with that
she's going to want to do everything
possible to be able to get
some kind of a piece of this cake so to
say and um you know doing something like
what was mentioned where she's going
she's getting the uh going in the trash
yeah like this is this is not something
that's that's new this is something
that's like women have been doing this
to high status men you know outside of
religion again for a long time
you know it's
it's a way for them to
have their shot
you know because if you think about it
if they get pregnant well okay now they
get the child support and that's a hefty
amount of Child Support when the man's
making millions if not billions you know
what I'm saying and then on top of that
she gets the uh the clout the attention
status that oh her baby is
so-and-so's you know what I'm saying so
it's like it's that's the first thing to
unpack
this is deep okay so high status man
she's going for the high status man and
it really doesn't even come down to if
you look at it like if you're so it's
not even how much is attraction like he
can be like the ugliest guy like not the
best looking or I mean his and and it's
like as long the main thing is the
status oh it depends like I said each
woman is gonna have a a different thing
that she sees as high value and it's sad
to say but I'll
I'll even say that it's in religious
women as well and just think about it
like if you have a religious woman
um all right it's maybe the highest
value Mayo would be like if it's a
mussima the highest value meal would be
the man who's you know God-fearing he
has takwa he prays he does everything
he's on Dean
um and then let's say you know he he's
over six foot he has a developed body
he's financially stable like he has his
own formal income
and whatever is she sees as high value
but let's say you have another brother
who comes into the picture
um he's also very God-fearing but he's
not as attractive he's not six foot his
body's not as developed
um but he has other things to him you
know he has other things other
attributes she'll probably choose the
the guy that she's more attracted to and
why is she more attracted to him
or a lot knows best but I must say it's
the the hypergamous thing where it's
like something inside her is seeing a
certain type of value in this man in
particular that's why she's being so
pool to him
and they've done studies on this this is
something that is uh supposedly they
have but again a lot of them like we
really don't know but we can see it like
happening you know
that's very interesting so um and in
this aspect that you mentioned it's not
necessarily A Bad Thing If you're
looking for it just the shift like from
now going towards someone like in this
case Drake
shifting over to someone who's actually
like you were saying righteous Pious
someone who's God-fearing okay totally
that's not a bad thing then it's not
it's not yeah and it's not a bad thing
okay if you got someone also at the same
time who's really into uh uh protecting
their not just their Iman but their
health right someone who's like you know
uh conscious of uh the vehicle that the
Creator is given to get him through life
so he exercises takes care of his body
his heart his mind so it's not necessary
it's not bad it's not bad at all it's
the perspective how you look at it it is
yeah but that's not the number one thing
right yeah it shouldn't be it shouldn't
be it shouldn't be but then again like
I'm not speaking for the Muslim sisters
out here I'm just saying like
um subjectively speaking
it could be in religious women as well
yeah you know what I'm saying yeah
but you can see like for instance I
don't mean to pick on Drake I mean we
want the best for him and inshallah we
can um we can invite him to the dean
also I mean but when you look at it's
not necessarily that he he's just in a
status that now he's got a a voice that
he uses it's like I always compare it to
the guy what's the guy with the flute
and he got all these mice following on
Peter Piper yeah you remember that yeah
hitting a little flute and the people
get mesmerized and they're just like you
know following him and you keep
following this guy potentially end up in
johannam you know and and I'll protect
us so he's not necessarily I mean if
like guys were to you know look he's
like okay he's not like the most uh you
know someone would say the most
attractive guy he can put he can be
putting all sorts of lines in his hair
doing all you know all these crazy funky
things he's like whatever but it's just
that's would you say it's the status
yeah because let's say he was just taken
out of that and he's just like your
regular guy now would he be like looked
at the way now people with the hot sauce
be happening uh probably not probably
okay probably not and let's look at this
okay if we look at what he's singing
about this is a for example one song
that they went crazy out about back and
this is very important because this goes
back into unpackaging another thing
these musical instruments right so this
is if you take out the musical
instruments and you just look at the
lyrics so let's let's diagnose let me
see what you think about this is this
going to be making people go crazy if
there's no musical instruments they're
just listening to these lyrics so this
is uh verse 1 drink Chubbs might Jam
this UT for a chain and give it to a
sweet one called the Maya Jane Gemma
given out gifts like Santa sipping on
Sana used to lean and woke
this is like Hooked on Phonics
closet filled up with designer
coming like panda panda yeah yeah
uh just came to the booth and asked for
a wheel she never heard drill drill in
Atlanta
Arabic thing told me that I took like
Yusuf
Arabic thing told me that I look like
Yusuf look like Hamza habiti please
now he's speaking Arabic you know so you
don't look like Yusuf can't even come
close to Yusuf alaihi salaam it's not
even that stuff
don't even come don't even he's bringing
he's singing look so he's singing about
let's stop right here
uh and we'll well let me just finish
this uh we'll go back with Papa skull
and Gaza and not that's not even worse
looks anyways it's like Hooked on
Phonics imagine no musical instruments
because the music is the hook right
that's the malware that gets in put the
disease so it can get into your mind and
body what do you think about this stuff
he's singing about what did he say in
Arabic he's Arabic thing told me that I
look like Yusuf get the hell but he
started like speaking in Arabic what was
he saying uh look like Hamza
habibti please
but then you started actually like
saying some Arabic uh and uh
what does that mean I'm not sure
habibti please that's my love
uh tell us in the in the comments what
is that what's he actually saying but uh
so now
you know this is how what do you think
what do you got in package here
uh
bits
again that's that's rap music that's any
kind of music you know like like you
said you use the instruments and that
hooks someone in like just like the the
story of Peter Piper you know where he
has a flute and he's Mesmerizing the
mouse or the mice
uh that's what music does it music it
mesmerizes you and it gets you to a
place of submission where you now submit
to the music because the moment that
your body starts to
started to kind of like move to the
music Set The Bobs to the music you've
already lost you've already lost because
at that point like subconsciously you're
just submitting to this Rhythm this
pattern this thing that's just moving
like this and once you've submitted to
this
basically this this auditory thing
that's happening right now
you now accept whatever is being said in
the lyrics so they could be saying
something good they could be saying
something bad whatever it is you're
accepting it I mean that's why people
listen to music and it has let's say the
guy he's he's a singing or rapping about
something emotional he's sad about
something then you start listening to
that and then you start feeling that
same emotion
and then you start like thinking about
certain things in your life and and it's
like well why why are you now thinking
this way why are you not feeling this
way is because the music affected you
why did the music affect you because you
submitted to it and you accepted
whatever it was transmitting to you so
it can be a dangerous thing man very
dangerous yeah I like what you said that
once you start bobbing your head
has got you right and
[Music]
um
it's a it's very deep because our Dean
you know even this aspect protects us is
a protection
for us you know if we follow it properly
that we don't fall into these pitfalls
and these traps of shaytan
right let alone going now to the
atmosphere that is played into the club
and then what happened to um
you know then in the car and your whole
life revolves just around bobbing your
head right and this is like uh you're in
a state of just
you're in a state of a lot you know uh
confusion loss you're just numb you're
just in a state of just numbness you
know yeah you know back in the day
uh when I used to listen to Drake stuff
for Allah there was this thing known as
uh don't drink and drive
oh don't Drake and drive don't drink and
drive I heard that where it's like if
you ended up driving while you were
listening to Drake what would end up
happening is that uh you would get so
emotional that you would end up at your
ex's house
and
let's go back to I mean the the lyrics
I'm sure I haven't heard these songs
you're talking about but if you were to
take just like I gave an example right
now we just took out no musical
instruments we're just reading like the
lyrics right so it goes back to the hook
they call it the and when I interviewed
like uh many former musicians and rap
artists they talk about this is like the
most important thing is the hook that
music the music instruments that hook
the person like it gotcha yeah and then
uh it's like the malware and then the
disease the virus is in that malware the
malware being the musical instruments
and then the poison gets in you through
there the virus oh yeah exactly
subhanallah so okay you know how you
have like empathy and then you have
apathy that's what it is those two right
empathy and apathy empathy and apathy
um empathy is or sympathy my bad
sympathy empathy and sympathy sympathy
is where you feel for someone
but it's like
that's as far as you go and then empathy
is like you feel what they're going
through so it's like you feel the same
pain that they're feeling right now
in a normal State the human being will
feel sympathy for When someone tells
them something like let's say
um you had someone telling you that they
were sad you know that their their
spouse just left them
right you could feel sympathy for them
and you might even feel a little bit of
empathy if you've been through something
similar correct but it's not going to be
the the same like you're not going to
feel the same exact thing that they felt
now if you listen to music
the moment that you submit if someone's
uh rapping or singing and they feel that
pain and they're telling you almost like
if I if the guy was telling you the same
thing but now he's saying it over music
you're submitting to the music so you're
accepting everything that he's saying
and now instead of you just having
sympathy and maybe a little bit empathy
you have
100 empathy as if it was your own pain
and that's um psychologically that
that's traumatic to us as humans like
especially humans who listen to music
all the time their emotional state their
psychological state is just bouncing all
over the place
so it's people hearing this for the
first time maybe some Drake fans people
tune in and they're like man these guys
are crazy man yeah but people who the
fit throughout were waking up to fit
through the natural
state of the human being you know that
that goodness is inside all human they
they relate I mean they can they can
depends how contaminated the fitra is
because uh to many people this is like
uh almost a religion right you wake up
to a go I I was in that state also
uh but then you have people who wake up
from it and then they they talk against
it uh because they've been there it's
like the whistleblowers too for real but
it's out of the love I mean just love
for for our our families you know in
humanity and even those closest to us I
can imagine our our sisters and the dean
daughters you know tomorrow to get may
God Almighty to create Allah protect us
it would be such a sad state to to see
and this is one of the intentions behind
like talking about this that if we can
awaken some hearts because we wouldn't
want and we've seen this I've
interviewed
uh former musicians like said earlier
who just totally now they accepted the
dean and they don't even want to do
because the guy knows the power of His
voice and he would go and he was just
doing uh nasheeds now I'm not saying you
know it's a good replacement hopefully
you know without the musical instruments
jumping into this but he didn't want to
do that you got to respect that why
because he said that you know the
sisters were you know how back in the
day when he was singing they would take
off their strings G you know what I'm
saying and they would throw it and the
sister was throwing hijab
stock for the law what the he's telling
me this stuff right he said I don't want
to play Eddie I don't want to you know I
don't want to be causing fitna so
imagine like you're in this state you're
listening to this guy Drake boy and
Drake uh 50 60 uh whoever I was out
there Snoopy and then what happens like
they you get the Peter Piper and it gets
the malware gets in you and now he says
come and you come like he did with this
Instagram so you want to say yes
that could be tomorrow you know someone
one of our so you got to have that taqwa
it's got to be sharp sound you know
otherwise you're going to be just pimped
like this this Deport this girl she was
uh pimped yeah for by shaytan oh yeah I
was about to say like well she
definitely chose this sub but now you
said she was pinned by shaytan like yeah
she definitely was what did she what is
she like her 15 minutes of fame
what is she like
at the end of the day
and for her now what I mean what would
you tell her now she's listening you
know she like the this is uh for you
sister in humanity
the best thing she could do right now
and we'll get to Drake later uh ladies
first ladies first
um I mean for her
it's hard to say anything because
she's probably not in a receptive place
um but if I were to say something
uh
say she's better than that you know and
and that's not coming from a place of
like
because you have this term in
like outside of Islam in the far world
you have this term called uh a simp
you know and I won't even go as far as
to a simp a simp I'm not gonna go as far
as to like say what the acronym means if
if one wants to look that up on their
own time by all means
um
but a Sim
like that's what you would say if
someone was
like would say what I just said were
like she's better than that you know
like uh Drake actually he has this and
few of his songs in the past he would uh
go to
these clubs the gentlemen's clubs so to
speak or you know you have these women
that they don't have anything on and he
would tell them like oh like you don't
have to do this for better than this
yeah shaking it for money yeah so he was
telling them like oh you don't have to
do this you're better than this and um
you would say that he would say that but
he was saying it from like a running
game
it's exactly he was trying to run games
so I'm trying to preface this by saying
like I'm not trying to run game I'm just
trying to like uh come at her like a
like she was my sister like genuinely if
she was my sister I would let her know
like look
um you're better than this like
everything that you're doing right now
what is it amounting like what is this
giving you at the end of the game like
what are you getting from all this you
know like let's say you do get the fame
let's say you do get the money let's say
you do get the attention and all of this
stuff everything you you could think
that you want but at the very end like
when it's all said and done
and you you don't have someone who who
truly cares about you and was truly with
you
um you don't have any direction in your
life you don't have any purpose you
don't have any reason for why you're
doing you're gonna have your emotions
and and just your state of being your
state of mind is all over the place
um no one really cares about you because
at the end of the day like when you're
famous it's just
it's status status comes and goes so
again like at the end of the day what
are you really getting from that you
know reflect on that you don't have to
answer it now but just reflect on it
because
you'll get to the point where you
realize okay I'm I'm not gonna receive
anything I'm Gonna Leave empty-handed
and
you know if you believe in the Creator
or not if you believe in the afterlife
or not like maybe
maybe now's the time Now's the Time yeah
that's a good point now reflect what's
my purpose in life why am I here
inshallah for the the people who are
living they don't fall in this trap you
know really be empowered that's that
taco when you have that consciousness of
Allah you're about to slip off then you
know my Creator is watching me right I'm
living for something more than this
temporary world I'm living for the
Hereafter you know Paradise is real
Hellfire is real I don't want to fall
into this you know trap that shaytan's
gonna just you know use and abuse me and
at the end he's gone and I'm by myself
just with my sins you know what I mean
Allah's most kind most merciful turn
back to your creator and Now's the Time
look into Islam sister
look into Islam just like you did you
looked into Islam you came from a
Catholic background yeah went towards
was it we talked about this before
Christianity and then you went to all
this third eye stuff
paranormal activities what Hinduism
Buddhism
[Music]
uh Taoism
[Music]
it's a lot and you saved the best for
last Islam yeah submission to the
Creator not the creation
yes for sure one God Alone yes sir and
then uh so people can see that story uh
about your journey but that so now being
in this state now to the point where
we're in the car and we're talking about
much of the things that now you learn
over the time about the beauty of Islam
we're talking about a bunch of things
back and forth that just it it it sense
how the heart into a state of uh peace
tranquility you know there's a good
there's a good feeling there right how
does that feel compared to before some
of the you know
conversations and good or bad whatever
he used to get involved in before
compared to now
so in regards to the conversations the
conversation before was always idle I
don't you know idle talk uh speaking
about random things that didn't matter
good video games could have been Sports
could have been just some gossip or
stuff like that but
it's like now
when you're in Islam like
your understanding is different
you know like you understand this is all
temporary so when you do have
conversations it's like okay well you
can speak about the temporary
or you can
keep that taqwa you can almost perform
like that uh like that form of thicker
where you guys are keeping the name of
Allah alive as you speak you know so
it's beneficial instead of something
that just doesn't give you anything so
there's definitely a big difference
there and um
like we said you know we were in the car
we were talking about a journey to Islam
and we're talking about all these things
and we had a lot on our tongues and
Allah not
so it's like even if that was our time
and we would have passed like that's it
would have been 100 all right because
we were in the state of taqwa we're in
the state of remembrance but now imagine
we were in that same situation and we
were talking about sports
are we talking about
um debt or bills or her finances or
something like that now imagine that
like
if if you were going to pass it that was
your time like would you have been
content knowing that you passed in that
state or would you have been content
knowing that you passed in a state of
remembrance
you know what I'm saying like there's
that thing that where it's like oh if
you're about to pass and you know like
it's your time like you you should say
like
you know so it's like it's
it's nine day difference in regards to
conversations
this is um whatever
one should have on their tongues and
their hearts and their tongues this is
uh such a powerful statement and I just
want to mention like
you know a lot of times when when people
let's say like the ones who are out
there and you know they can relate to a
lot of times a lot of the things we're
saying like when we talk about death
uh you see so many of these athletes now
just dropping dead you know healthy
you know alive and they're playing
soccer playing some sport I don't know
if you saw some of these these just
collapsing they're just collapsing you
know these athletes so people think I
have time I have time I have time right
so then people fall in the state of
cognitive dissonance you know they're
just like oh I got you know they they
they can't fathom that reality like but
there's another reality coming just like
you can't imagine that you were in a
placenta one time you're in a placenta
and then you just came out of that the
placenta you know is gone and now you're
in this
life and compare that a small space to
this now there's something greater
waiting for for the believer but what I
wanted to mention was it doesn't mean
that you're just like locked up in a the
house of worship all day with the Masjid
the mosque you still living life you
want to be a business personality a
businessman you're the best at that you
have irsan if you want to be a sports
person you're teaching people like you
know how to be healthy or eat healthy
what you're the best at that but at the
end of the day you don't sell your soul
for you know some hot sauce with Drake
All right you got morals you got
principles you stand on some truth at
the end of the day and you don't succumb
to and and if you do again we're all
human beings we can make mistakes you
got a lord who's the most merciful the
most kind he didn't send someone to die
for you no he's the most forgiving you
can go ahead and ask the Creator alone
for forgiven and he'll forgive you you
know what I mean and then just drive
your best not to go follow up a bad deal
with a good deed right and keep striving
for the ultimate success with his gender
Paradise
yeah 100 percent
it's um
I don't know man I definitely had
something to say but
uh my mind went blink
but yeah I agree 100 percent
I um going back to how we started
this um and it took it took a while
we're driving
and uh we're just talking so I want you
guys to imagine we're talking what do
you remember exactly where we were in a
conversation what what was it
you were telling me like what was the
turning point for you like in your heart
becoming Muslim to start okay going
towards Islam right yeah and then you
were telling me how like you started
kind of questioning these things like
trying to find the answers and I think
you were talking to your I think it was
Uncle my uncle yes your uncle and he had
like giving you this book life's
definitely Hereafter yeah okay so we
were there in the conversation someone
uh so I got this book life definitely
Hereafter we're talking I want you guys
to imagine
um
and then from there
someone just swerves in so I gotta take
a sharp turn I start turning towards the
left and then the divider between the
other side is there and then it all that
just quickly happened I don't know if
the car went back what it was but we
could have hit that wall if we would hit
that wall we're going pretty fast right
normal speed limit 60 miles or something
an hour yeah we hit that wall could have
spun out who knows it could have been
dead so maybe all those other trucks
like right next to us and everything so
those other we almost we could almost
die yeah subhanah look how quickly life
can just take a turn subhanallah yeah
but I like what you said that got us a
little we were happy elated about that
yeah so what'd you say I said we had we
had Allah in our minds or a law in our
tongue
and Allah in our hearts and I implied as
well a lot in our mind but you get it so
brothers and sisters I want you if
you're I mean look I'm calling it out
I'm calling out if you're listening to
Drake
hallelu DJ Khalid you heard of this guy
isn't he Muslim
yeah he's Muslim may Allah guide him we
want the best for DJ Khalid we want the
best for you DJ Khalid you can what he's
he gives those like you know you are
beautiful you are Khalid come on man a
Muslims one who submits his will now
we're talking about DJ Khaled now we
want we got love for all these people
out there that's the dean the prophet
saws look he came as a mercy for all of
mankind but whose side are you on are
you helping people get pimped by shaytan
right or are you calling people to the
truth right so you these two don't mix
man yeah right
so um what was I saying so I was saying
like look if you're listening to DJ
Khalid if you're listening to Drake if
you're listening to 55 60 I'm sorry you
said it's 50 cents for any of these
people it can be Kid Rock I I don't know
the latest who are out there they got
some of these guys are just screaming
stuff it just it's I don't know that is
true cut it out today man yeah throw it
out replace it with something better
replace it with Quran replace it with
some what would you replace it with like
let's say myself if I'm working out I
have I put on like uh the headphones and
I'm listening to let's say audiobook a
lecture I'm listening to something
that's going to empower my mind my heart
my body what do you what do you suggest
if someone's working out and they feel
like they need music like
well number one like that's a dependency
so that's you know you should already be
trying to get away from that but number
two like if you don't want to listen to
music and there's a gym that's there's a
music playing like work out outside
you can buy some gymnastic Rings or you
can find somewhere that has a bar and to
do pull-ups or you can get yourself some
stuff to be able to do weightlifting if
that's what you want to do outside
you know what I'm saying like there's
always
an option there's always another choice
you never stuck exactly where you are
with what's going on and um I wanted to
hit on this you know like it came to me
while you were saying it about all the
rappers and everything where it's like
you know we it's all about Islam and all
that well just think about this
there's two types of people in this
world
you have the people who invite you to
the good
and those who invite you to the bed
now these rappers people who are outside
of Islam outside of religion in general
they follow their nafs they follow their
desires so it's their ego that's in
control but little do they know that
it's there's something else that's in
control of their ego
and we know clearly what that said what
that is
shaitan is the one that's in control of
our ego if there is no higher purpose
higher power or just like the guidelines
that keep us on a straight path because
we fall astray and if we're straight our
ego tends to take over and something
else has to be in control of our ego
because our ego is just it's
ego's not it's not really anything you
know what I'm saying it's just a
construct it's a creation so
have our egos in control
think about your own ego think about how
like your ego wants like it wants power
it wants respect
it wants money it wants uh
you know I'm
they want sexual relations it wants
women and if you're a woman it obviously
wants men like the lust
right like it's it's all the um the
worldly things the
uh the carnal desires of this world he
wants to eat food it wants to be
gluttonous it wants to enjoy itself it
wants to just party and have fun all
this stuff like all right now if you
understand okay that's where the ego is
coming from
and you understand that this person is
being controlled by the ego like do you
think they're calling you the good at
that point no
not at all no
that's what I'm saying and I want I want
people to get this um check this
perspective like you have laws in place
and you have
the institutions that are out there
monitoring if let's say somebody was
inciting or had some influence of
someone committing a crime right that
they'll go after this person
all right being affiliate somebody who
was an accomplice let's say somehow he
was maybe that person didn't even do the
crime but somehow he motivated someone
to do the crime you get you get the
point now let's switch this over to here
these are accomplices people who are
helping open a door for people to go
towards Zina fornication to goes towards
drugs to go towards alcohol all the
things that are breaking the law of the
creator of the heavens and the Earth so
you see the example I'm striking right
so the Drake's out there the khalidas
scenes and all the other ones um what's
the other it's sad to say people who are
Muslim and we people get excited that's
why and again this is not to say like oh
we're better than these people this that
and the other no they can be better
tomorrow they can come out imagine if
Drake accepted the dean the purpose of
life and he got out there imagine how
much good he can do so that's the
motivating Point that's the love given
to these people come come to the Deen
come to Islam you know instead of
worshiping your desires calling other
people to all this heedlessness and all
of this debauchery and all these things
you're going to be accountable in front
of the created heavens and earth and the
end of the day is hellfire right but you
can turn around and God Almighty can
turn those baddies into good deeds and
you can go ahead and start setting a
good example and you can get to Jannah
and Shalom be better than all of us and
everything that we're doing imagine the
kind of good that
Khalid and uh Drake can be doing all you
know for real and what's sad is that the
biggest lie that uh is gonna run through
their head if they ever think about this
and and I'm speaking more so for Drake q
but also you know for others uh is that
if I leave this if I go to Islam
or if they just choose to live a more
simple life religious life
they're going to lose everything they're
going to lose the status they're going
to lose the the money and they're gonna
lose the just everything that they have
right now and and to them like
it almost like freezes them and keeps
them stuck it doesn't they don't want to
lose that they don't want to get rid of
that but they they need to understand
like whatever you give up for the sake
of your creator like your creator is
going to give you tenfold that
you know like I wanted to be a
professional fighter before I became
Muslim now I'm Muslim and it's like you
know what I gave that up and now Allah
has given me so much more alhamdulillah
so it's like with them they need to
understand like
you're not giving up anything really you
actually
accepting so much more blessing so much
more uh just so much more in life and in
regards to DJ Khaled and DJ Haddon
however you say
um
we the best you know yeah yeah it's a
man it if he's Muslim you know Allah
right because in his heart he could be
Muslim Allah Knows Best
um he says he is he says he prays he
says he does a lot of stuff
but brother like just think about the
music you make think about the things
you speak of like you said you are you
really inviting someone to the good or
are you inviting them to the fitna to
the zinna to the stuff like that you
know and like and again like he might be
having that same thing running his head
where it's like
should I let this go because there's so
much that I have right now that if I let
this go like and I go to Islam like then
what is there really for me
you know but again like this is just
subjective
because again he might be more Muslim
than I am Allah knows best we just for
what we see from the outside you know so
DJ Khaled I mean
um again he can be better than you know
most of the people out there if you take
what Allah has given you now you have a
responsibility like you're talking about
you're either inviting people to good or
to evil and you you can't if somebody
told you if I said look if you keep
going down this path if you keep
breaking the law of the land for
instance I said you're going to go to
jail let's say the person selling
cocaine let's say they're you know uh
committing fraud they're embezzling
they're doing all sorts of you know
things that if you look at the law the
statues it's to 20 years 10 years you
know 15 years so you're gonna get life
in prison man
right you would think okay this guy he's
concerned for me he cares for me
but over here you break there's laws
there's laws you're breaking the laws of
the creator of the heavens and the Earth
and they carry a sentence man you're
going to end up in them right you're
going to end up like so when a person
mentions that out of love and concern
then people like use the card don't
judge him don't judge me what do you say
to that
I think I think it it's ignorance
you know because
Drake even has a song where he says um
if I can remember the lyrics here he
says uh
he at one point he's like I cannot see
Heaven being much better than this
um
look at my people from the six um I
don't okay I don't know 100 but at some
point he did say I can't see Heaven
being much better than this and it's
like
um that's ignorance he's talking about
this world yeah so from what he's
experiencing because like he has all the
abundance he has all the money and every
time that but like he forgets and most
people who have the abundance forget
that like scarcity and abundance are
tests and a bonus is more of a test than
scarcity because in scarcity you don't
have anything yeah so it's like you you
are in a very low state so it's very
easy for you to be humble and be
grateful for whatever you receive but
when you have abundance
like it's very hard to be humble because
you have it all you know what I'm saying
subhanallah we've unpackaged a lot man
inshallah this can be of benefit to so
many people it reminds me of a Hadith a
saying of the last and final message you
sent to mankind Prophet Muhammad peace
and blessings be upon Him office he's a
brother to Jesus Moses Abraham
he came with the same message worship
one and only one creator of the heavens
and earth and be morally upright we have
the Quran verbatim word of God Almighty
I don't get to preach you here but look
he said that for the believer
who had struggled and strived you know
to be you know upright he made mistakes
upon mistakes
you know he had a hard life
and then he the belief he or she will be
dipped into Jannah just for you know a
second and then
he'll be asked did you experiencing
anything
bad in this life now just imagine all
the struggles I'm talking about you know
just the worst of the worst things you
can imagine all right but the person was
committed to Dean that taqwa right
always in a state of turning back Toba
repentance huh held on to the toheed and
then he'll be asked like did you
experiencing anything bad in this life
compared to the good rewards that's
coming he said no and he'll wish to go
back to experience more because of the
reward that's coming in general remember
that's Eternal Paradise Eternal then he
gave an example but for the person who
had everything
in this life can you imagine everything
and Beyond like the the kings of Kings
right and that person who now let's say
deny God worship His desires you know
and the the world just opened up to that
person right never thought to make
repentance right never thought to you
know ask for guidance never thought of
his creator you know what I mean misled
people like you know the Drakes of the
world right unless they turn back and
there's still hope if they do but now
that person and that made me think of
what you're saying they're experiencing
Paradise like he said there's you know
uh this is it like this is the paradise
so he's experiencing Paris Paradise on
Earth that person will be dipped in the
Hell Fire just for one second and then
asked did you experience experience
anything good in this life but he did
right he experienced all the he followed
his desires till death if he dies on
that
he'll say no she'll say no imagine and
then that person would be thrown in the
Hellfire
this is deep
can you imagine that
subhanallah
because uh just imagine like for the
people Ramadan is coming up soon the
last Ramadan that passed there was the
Pains of hunger right but those pains of
hunger are not are gone now right do you
do you uh you don't feel no more but the
reward is still with you look at that
the person now who experiencing you know
that Instagram moment with the hot sauce
and stuff that feeling that good feeling
is gone for him right it's gone but the
sin Still Remains unless the person
makes Toba yeah then is is sad man it's
so bizarre even the people who listen to
this and they're like
this is all like fake this is this
doesn't make any sense or something like
that it's like
you you might say that but you know when
your heart is there because like even
when I was in a state of disbelief
like I still knew when I was missing the
mark when I was off the um
I guess you just call it the straight
path I didn't know it was a Street Path
but I knew like I was just like if I had
a bone arrow and I'm aiming towards a
Target I was not hitting the target I
was hitting somewhere else and I knew it
I clearly knew when I was doing
something wrong and that was um
like tainting my being you know I didn't
I didn't believe in the soul or anything
but it was tainting the soul tainting
the heart
and like these people who they don't
believe and and they just they don't
even think about these things like voila
he's like it's there
is there deep down like it's happening
and that's why
um they are not at ease they are not in
peace and happiness and uh have that
clear Direction
because like even if they think that
they're free even if they think that
they're experiencing a life that they
want to experience they're actually not
because they're going against themselves
and and they are essentially like I said
they're missing the mark
but yeah
I like to take the the remaining time
and
if Drake Tunes in his fans DJ Khaled we
had messages for both of them
and then for Drake and then that uh
the the sister in humanity who also we
invite them to really do something
really simple
you know really reflect on what the
purpose of life is why am I here where
did I come from how long am I going to
be in this life
and then what's my ultimate purpose in
life and I often leave people with the
homework it's real simple ask the
Creator that happens on Earth no
intermediary no intercessor just the one
who created you asked for guidance I
mean real simple I mean at what point I
remember when we talked before did you
start doing that and then you ended up
accepting Islam like how would you
advise them because again you probably
coming from a background they came from
maybe Catholic you're also a Christian
and then also you did all the third eye
stuff the crystals I mean you
experimented with all the different you
know man-made religions out there uh
from your advice now how would you tell
them you know if you're talking to Drake
right now and you want to invite them or
DJ Khaled you want to invite them to
Islam my genuine
invitation would be like look you have
all the money
and all the time that you could have
asked for so take
take a few weeks and just be by yourself
out in nature with like no electronics
or anything
nothing no distractions and just see
what comes to you
and I'll leave it there I'll leave it
there
and then often uh you know we we uh
we
um have so many shows that we've done
that go into if someone wants to go
deeper we have
all because Islam is something a lot of
times people equate religion with it's
just uh blind belief you know and the
Beautiful Thing for myself
you know when I start to see the
hundreds upon hundreds of miracles in
the Quran that there's no way that this
could come from a human being you know
the preservation of the Quran you know
you have um the splitting of the Moon
the prophecies so many things the life
of prophet Muhammad so now if somebody
goes and digs deeper and they turn their
thinking skull on their hat they start
to investigate these things it's the
Miracles that Prophet Muhammad usually
people don't talk about that they talk
about the miracles of Jesus then the
belief in Jesus the love that we have
for Jesus uh the chapter named after his
blessed mother Mary in the Quran now
we're getting deep I mean this is these
are all topics we've done you can go to
the deanshow.com and you can type in the
splitting of the Moon you can type in
science uh uh chronic Miracles so it's
not something that you blindly jump into
right so this is something that is for
the thinking person someone who reflects
Beyond just the material besides just
imperialism in the hot sauce
but I like how you said reflect you know
that and that's what I was trying to get
at with my point is like I like that
take the few weeks and just reflect
because through reflection you will
start to come to the answers to the
questions that you're asking deep down
you know and Allah it says in the Quran
like
do they not use their
their mind to reflect
yes yeah so it's like start with the
reflection and then from there like
it'll lead you to uh certain questions
that you might have and if you keep
seeking if you keep looking for the
answers which if you look for the
answers you'll find the answers that's a
beautiful thing is like there's not
there's not a question that doesn't have
an answer in this world alhamdulillah so
if you reflect then you're gonna have
these questions and then if you are
sincere and you keep looking for the
answers you're gonna receive the answers
and and the answers inevitably
end up in Islam
yeah and I want people to get caught up
with the um with this the the term Islam
I always Define these words Islam if
you're searching for peace I'm sure you
are in life contentment that's how you
get it by submitting your will to the
creator of the heavens and earth that's
what Islam means and the Muslim is one
who submits his or her will to the
creator of heavens and earth just to uh
before we conclude let's go back to um
really becoming worm Buffet if you think
about it you know
um and I think this this should be
something that we started the show we'll
end with it also here we're reflecting
upon death that reality where if you
bring it up people get really nervous
they make a joke about it and they
change the subject but it's something
that is should be a heart softener
soften our heart because the hearts
become like a rock and then when the
truth tries to penetrate it's so hard
but in these moments like this this girl
uh she's probably hopefully it's a
moment where she's like devastated
hopefully maybe it's not I don't know
but or sisters out there who've been
um you know in situations they've been
raped right this is what happens you
know the guy gets you into
um his place the clubs they put the
Mickey was it a Mickey in the drink
what's it called you know it's uh
roofies roofies right these are real
things that are happening put you on the
dope on the drugs and I got Daybreak at
the whole team comes in right whole team
goes out and now you're left scarred for
life Islam protects you from that no
alcohol no illicit relationships none of
these things you know but connects you
to one who loves you loves you more that
anyone could love you your creator you
know
and and people think you know how you
said like you mentioned that and people
get like kind of like oh they get like a
little nervous or they just get kind of
weird they don't want to talk about it
and say you don't want to talk about it
because you don't know what's going to
happen yeah you know and because you
don't know what happened what's gonna
happen you don't feel ready for death so
that's why you feel uncomfortable
speaking about it or thinking about it
and you don't want to reflect on it but
it's like listen if you if you
understand your purpose here
if you understand what the whole point
of all this is then you have
understanding of what happens after
death
and therefore when you think about that
or or talk about this or reflect upon it
it's not uncomfortable
it's more like you said it's softening
it's enlightening because it wakes you
up again it wakes you up and makes you
say like ah yeah like that that's what's
gonna happen you know like at some point
this journey is going to end and then
the next Journey will begin you know and
it gives you that Assurance therefore
you are
um you know you're not uncomfortable
because you know what's going to happen
you know what I'm saying and Islam has
from A to Z that's the beautiful thing
about this Dean from A to Z it has
everything all the steps from when the
soul leaves the body yeah and now the
Angels come and say oh good Soul come
out to the mercy of your lord and his
pleasure or the opposite so it has
everything then the life in the grave
and this is what just fascinated me and
scared me you know so much but it's not
just that like you hear oh he just he's
in a better place rest in peace you know
to me did you did you work for that
piece in the Hereafter yes yeah did you
work for it huh so don't be in a state
like you know of denial and I like what
you said when you know what's going to
happen next you enjoy talking about it
and Islam has it like no other uh
religion way of life because Islam is
from the crater it's not counterfeit
it's not mad made uh so
we're about out of time so for the
hamzas out there
for the aishas the habdeepthis and and
whatnot the habibis who are they have
this Deen they've been exposed to it you
know but now the fitna comes what advice
do you have you've been you've
experienced all these things so from
your eyes you know so the youth you know
they don't fall into and go they want to
let me just let me just see for myself
the club let me just see for myself what
it is to experience some of these things
and then boom you you get caught and
trapped it just takes that one time and
you're you're you're lost so what do you
what do you say for the youthful like
you know they get called by their
friends come on come on let's go let's
go Here There and Everywhere and whatnot
and they want to you know just just yeah
taste it yeah so it it kind of goes like
that thing where it's like
when he told not to do something you
want to do it even more yeah you know so
uh for the Muslims out here or the
Muslim men the Muslims
who are
they have all these things they've never
done it they've never experienced it so
it's like a part of the monster you know
like go like I kind of want to see what
this is about I kind of want to see what
happens here like take it from a brother
who has reverted who has experienced all
these things unfortunately not gonna say
what I've done what I've experienced
Allah has placed the covering on that
alhamdulillah
but none of it is worth it
like you
from all the things that I experienced
none of it was worth it even for like a
Split Second
and if I could go back I would actually
not do that I would tell myself look
like this it's just not necessary it's
not needed and like sadly you know some
people are those people who have to like
they have to hit their head on the walls
and experience it themselves and
um I don't I don't wish that for anyone
I'm just saying like look it's not what
your mind is making it out to be like
it's not the grass isn't green on the
other side and if if you just kind of
how it does if you don't have that full
like conviction and you just kind of
wavering and and you're being pulled in
all these different directions like take
a step back
and reflect
just like I told to to Drake or to DJ
Khaled or 50 Cent or whatever like that
it all starts with reflection because
even as a Muslim
if we reflect it always brings us back
to Allah you know
and Hell
my brother yes sir
I got it right this time I just saw you
did I don't know thank you so much where
can people uh
you know hook up with you you got uh
where's where's your brother
Canada they in Canada right now but if
if you want to link up with three
Muslims the three Muslims like oh you
know what I say uh look up on YouTube
the three Muslims
and you'll find everything over there
inshallah very nice real nice discussion
we have packaged a lot inshallah it can
be of benefit inshallah thank you and
for you guys uh tuning in go ahead did
you know that you can get a free you
heard us mention the Quran you want to
see for yourself go ahead and visit
thedeenshow.com you get the Quran as a
gift from us free and if you ask some
questions
uh you want to visit maybe a moss you
want to uh you know learn more and you
want to talk to someone
1-800-662-4752 we're here to help you
along your way subscribe go hit that
notification Bell and if you knew that
just by hitting that like button and
this can get some traction and it can be
a benefit of people you get rewarded you
probably hit it so go ahead and hit it
and we'll see you next time inshallah
here on the dean show until then peace
be with you